marine lepen has plenty to be pleased
about she's just been unanimously
re-elected as party leader and if
presidential elections were held today
polls say she would take the top job
three years ago she replaced her father
jean-marie Le Pen at the head of the
far-right party the 86 year old party
founder was seen as something of a
liability frightening off potential
voters with anti-semitic and racist
remarks his daughter is more moderate
and tone projecting a down-to-earth
hardworking image and yet the National
Front remains in many ways a dynasty at
the latest party conference the Pens
nice Mountain mashaallah pen was voted
into the party's Central Committee at 24
she's Frances youngest lawmaker and her
opinions are clear let me remind you
that under Nicolas Sarkozy there were
200,000 illegal entries every year more
than sixty percent of this immigration
is family and social immigration it's
not work based immigration we were told
we could choose our immigrants left-wing
groups demonstrated outside the
conference on saturday and scuffles
broke out with police outside the venue
inside National Front delegates were
already dreaming of the next presidency
I sincerely think marine will be
President the sooner the better because
Frances situation keeps worsening
politics look set to remain turbulent in
France